is starting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right testing testing what's going
on in the realm
fc violet what's going on regulating
what's going on let me know if my levels
is good we're just
trying to fill the room up before king
and everybody get in here
i think have a little camera issue but
we got my man wilhelm scream
one of the best destiny creators welcome
talk to the people right now
hello everybody welcome to the iron
lords podcast
you sound like you've been wanting to
say that
best podcast around for all your destiny
as well as
xbox ps4 ps5 oh
daddy what's going on man absolutely
violet stop being messy he said destiny
yes he did i'll be a mess
be here for destiny too
hey what's going on everybody you
already know that sinister that's one of
the best destiny players
in the clan we get all our free stuff
from him
that's my backpack right that's
[Laughter]
[Music]
cat daddy what's going on all right alex
he might be having a camera issue but
he's going to come back
i think it's done man all the camera
cameras
i'm waving in front of you you can see
me waving in front of it yeah
but nothing's [ __ ] up i've reset well
you try some different things all right
we're gonna work out the technical
difficulties i'm gonna mute
that yeah we got the squad in there we
got the iop squad in there today but
we're looking for gamescom
king should be pulling up i don't know
if anybody else is pulling up in a room
if you got one in just
dm or whatever live stream yo they said
you got the tcl okay come on don't go
go for a man like that
you you know i'm a mod right now that's
the homie that's all
good anyway we will mute and then we'll
roll up in there get y'all right talk to
you out a bit y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
all right all right all right
what's going on y'all what's going on
y'all hopefully
y'all can hear us the levels is good you
already see the kings in the rum and all
that good stuff
we're gonna get this stream percolating
you know what i'm saying
so y'all know what's going on what's up
medic what's up y'all
so we're gonna get this stream popping
when we watching today
we go right now we're going to do
twitter oh i thought
you were we watched i think what did we
watch what are we doing
all right you're watching it on twitch
okay i'm going to watch it
let me know how these stream levels are
versus our voices if you want them
louder
the whole bit because normally you guys
say that y'all like
us louder but you're gonna do a mic
check right
they'd quick like yeah i don't want to
hear them guys they sound low to me
but the who are we watching watching the
twitch stream of the game awards show
the cat daddy alert
the 10 hour super chat have you been
harassed about your tv of choice
has someone made you feel as if your
panel is less than adequate
take pride in your black friday purchase
what's more visiting
stopbullying.com you're beautiful salute
camp daddy for being best daddy i feel
like i've been attacked so much i feel
like that should be my money
these streams are kind of low i'm
turning them up they sound low
we five minutes out on them dudes but
usually what happens the live stream
will
actually kick up volume so we'll see how
it would go as it goes
all right your voices are really oh yeah
that's what it feels like to me so i'm
going to turn it up
[Music]
because i feel there very well and then
we'll see we got the
magic we'll see how it goes
[Music]
thank you appreciate you yo
that's how they the game go oh that's
that dirt right that's that 120 frames
oh wait a second he did create mode and
they just started dropping stuff down
that's nick jim what we'll do is
sometimes when they go live the uh
production teams will turn up the stream
even louder
so if it gets too loud let us know also
chat
so we'll see how i go but i appreciate
y'all yo sir first off um
yeah casual red phone forward table yo
salute to all the love out there in the
room and i see y'all
see y'all in the comments for the ign
joint you know
much appreciate it made your boy shed a
tear man the love was coming to
respect to the realm on that so you
think like a vampire
bit a car sucked out gas
to be continued it is now time for the
part of the pre-show
that i've been i've been reading your
live comments i see them right now
everybody's blowing up demanding kyle's
ten
to reasons excited for opening night
live 2020 feeling excited for next gen
again
number nine jeff keeley wardrobe reveal
number eight reason to be excited for
opening night live 2020 destiny trailer
is usually pretty good my mic's a little
pre-show is finally over number six call
of duty black ops cold war
number five reason to be excited for onl
2020
i have no idea who this man is number
four
fall guys season two number three
and the number one reason to be excited
for opening night live
2020
we have one final world premiere trailer
to show off and this trailer isn't an
announcement
uh how's my level version move myself up
a little bit let me know if i got a
little loud
that can only be described as dinosaurs
in the building enjoy that thing in the
building
javier mccain thank you all you already
know support
i think that things are going to turn
out differently huh
because they believed that they were in
control
and control well
here's the thing humanity is desperate
for it
this is that jurassic park evolution
which gang coming in hot possess
oh man i don't got my emoji on deck for
this
you see life gonna be tenacious let's go
king
what makes us such unique creatures can
you see in this
knowing the power of what we're up
against
just like sim city
[Music]
[Music]
bushes hey it's running better than ark
it's running better than arc y'all
switch pro coming in hot thank you chris
you already know the vlog please be
excited for the actual
opening night live in which you'll see
all right
that mysterious playstation 5 demo some
things we've probably never heard of
before
i think it's going to be a very good
show i'm personally excited about it
me i should thank you actually for
putting up with my nonsense for the last
20 minutes it is appreciated
but seriously enjoy the show are you
ready you ready what you excited for
death
well my age of empire's three i want to
see what it's looking like it's time
good
to take control of our world when we
feel out of place
anything else is a bonus and divided
there are always repercussions do we
have what it takes
to do dlc as well
baby what's up spiderman final super
chat i'm a ups driver i can't deliver a
tcl without laughing thanks king welcome
you're welcome 2020.
now this year gamescom is of course a
little different than normal and i hope
all of you and your families
are safe and healthy at home in 2020
games have comforted and connected us
more than ever and with the launch of
playstation 5 and xbox series x later
this year
only going to get better well all summer
i was hopeful we could get to this very
moment
to stuff this out now
this is the worst extended
for gameplay 5. surprises along the way
too
but before we start i want to
acknowledge and thank all
the game developers marketers and
publishers who have worked
under challenging circumstances to keep
us entertained
this show is nothing without them or my
production team
and doing a show at this scale safely is
not easy
especially when all of you at home have
some pretty insane expectations
i hope tonight reminds you why you
raven to tell us about the game and give
you an exclusive
sneak peek yo i think that's the only
game they got to work
with
a little bit we knew black ops
deniable operations conspiracy ground in
history
and that shadow of paranoia
and it's really something that we know
relevant to today
and also uniquely black ops that
background
on a wall right yeah he's talking to the
guy right now he told them
forward
personalities mixed with some of the new
characters so the campaign takes place
and
you're pushing the storytelling in kind
of a new direction with some branches
and some options about how you play
through the campaign can you maybe walk
us through your thinking there
yeah one of the driving forces from
early in development was to say let's
take this black ops through a ride
and infuse it with some player choice
and some player freedom anything we can
do to give the player a little more
ownership over their experience
so that starts with allowing the player
to create their own character for the
cold war campaign
they can name them and pick a military
background and really
pretend they are that black ops soldier
that they want to be
from there we wanted to take some of our
missions and infuse
optional objectives multiple paths and
some player choice moments
inside some of these missions and it was
fun to find that balance between the
hard driving call of duty action
and these more non-linear experiences
and something you see at the bottom of
the screen it said right
all this footage captured on the series
oh yeah i remember the numbers all right
well dan
are you excited to see more of it i know
multiplayer reveals coming in september
but
uh
the first time we've shown this outside
the walls of the development studio
this is
i like the 60 frames per second you
already know that's on the x
so um okay guys check it out information
from the manhattan project was stolen
from us we know we go we know
they should go for that cinematic first
um you're going to get that 30 frames
per second
mr hudson where are all the wheels
world premiere we're also aware he's
more myth that's what we gotta get we
gotta get a logo that's a world premiere
world premiere i can't wait till we put
that position
take your spot
uh here we go here we go
oh you see that hdr when they open the
lights up in the room
crispy
that's starting up dude that's the ps5
i'm talking about
ridiculous with your man mouth though
they got black oh they got the o.g
mr president sir mr president mr
president this is
jason hudson and russell abbott with
their names
we can sir i've already submitted the
requisition for my team
sir man i think i got to watch them
twitch
twitch most likely i'm not doing the
cutscenes are you talking about oh no
it's not even about that
my job is crazy beautiful that's just a
haze that's all
plausible deniability is the backbone of
our work
we're talking about preventing an attack
on the free men and women of the world
you've been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
there is no higher duty there is no
higher odds
also
know of your struggles rest assured
the entire free world will be well yeah
jersey should be there today well
i should have gotten feelings i
shouldn't know i even know he's around
man we'll be higher
tonight we have some biggest ones for
you guys as well
including this one next gen narrative
action adventure game
that you know they ain't got nothing
montreal
a woman raised on the streets of india
and haunted by visions of her own death
haruna struggles to understand her
mysterious innate abilities
to manipulate the unseen check out this
first look
okay first i got about me i got a text
from best buy what do you say tcl's
inbound
let's check it out new jersey
in the building
[Music]
yeah i just switched over it's way
better on
the whole thing is i gotta download it
ain't got twitch on this crap
[Music]
a little cinematic trailer yeah
get to a game no game play no game play
but no
oh yo i spoke too soon
looks like an engine right here
wow they felt like they needed to come
back and show that oh that that was like
yeah that was definitely the big switch
i thought it was going down
believe in the other debate and next
generation consoles
okay all right
yeah they fooled me i thought that
breakfast let's get into it play
one of this year's biggest games i like
the culture eternal tonight we've got an
exclusive first look
at the campaign expansion called the
ancient
part one check this out
you got a real unnatural thing if
anything that looks dangerous
at
he's a weirdo
it'd be like the shittiest game in the
world he's like it's got a knife
that knife looked at crispy come on it's
covering his nose
let's get it new maternity
i better stand up
oh okay all right okay
did you play this game i played doom
forever
this is doom yeah
we got some frame facing little frame
facing
talk about that frame basically the
playstation version
is regretting that playstation marketing
now
this can't be showing it like there's
not like this
world premiere not like this
2020 marks the 25th anniversary of a
legendary game
studio bioware oh casey hudson and the
team
oh give everyone the world a little bit
we've been imagining new ways to use
next-generation technology
to bring the world in characters of
dragon age slow-mo i'm about to go crazy
early production it's it's he just said
he's dragging it very first look
dragon age passionate team of developers
are crafting this very special game
canada stand up
let's get it the rebirth the ogs
calm down let's listen to the trailer
from a company of 35 people to a company
of more than 300 people
those amazing people in the industry
there's amazing stories
so much we're very experimental here
they need to get the answers that you
have there it's the rebirth we're always
just
go slow-mo
we need this for the culture you all get
to see that
statue this better not be concept this
better not be concept of the whole show
though
let's go frontier stories it's got
mystery it's got hard-boiled detective
stories
[Music]
i'm done with this game this game lied
to me in the beginning
these are the gods these are the
creators the architects this is an
original
that game is the business
ain't nothing you doing okay again
[Music]
and grew up in these spaces as well he
said this is a recruitment video
we don't have nobody to let me help me
this needs to be good
if this isn't good then aren't willing
to address the issues
that's
with game characters who really become
real for you
we want characters come on by the way
every every day i've got ray tracing
right here
oh so lost let's go oh we're getting
better you're getting closer
put your soul awesome i know what time
it is
what will they call you when this is
over let's get it
four
the way they walk runners move and
interact in the world
players wanting that suspension of
disbelief that this
wonderful collection of digital pixels
is actually a living breathing soul
no no it's okay that's the good kind of
rumble
i actually designed bosses i help with
the creature design team as well so i do
all like the big threats that you have
to go up against
nobody dies on my watch oh let's go for
the wardens
for the wardens part of what dragon age
is as a franchise
the decisions you make can affect change
in the world decision
making can mean that a party member
lives or a party member dies
it means owning your outcome and
is what gets you up in the morning it's
a fantastic
opportunity the rebirth every time
[Music]
oh come on y'all you just concentrate me
on the end
i need you next stop
oh that was the ultimate tease wow
wow
[Music]
uh-oh i think there's a serious
miscalculation
wow wait you're uh what what's his name
here's the tragedy
doctor of physics absolutely not that
quack
yeah we know who you are but what you're
doing here i did come back from the
future to this
precise moment on august 27 2020
because it's imperative we launched
certain simulator two
[Music]
tonight i watch a world premiere i don't
know how he still got here on his head
that's the question i'm talking about
right here what is he drinking that's
cgi
he's saying his eyebrows
speaking of time i'm off to another
world premiere
avengers 26
this is all playstation you can get this
day one completely cinematic playstation
vr there you go
throw your helmet on and stick your
hands inside somebody guts
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening
[Music]
oh
that's crazy man teaching people how to
be seriously malicious
playing certain simulator live
all right well if you thought that
crossover was kind of crazy
wait until you get a load of this next
game announcement that
i don't think anyone probably saw coming
check this out
no one saw nothing coming
no i gotta find oh never mind i'm
already done
an engine y'all
[Music]
this napoleon dynamite want a female
let's get let's move on with this
man somebody said pubg too i'm dead
you got a level one backpack
oh g2 he's gonna play the actual game on
the
computer
they didn't even have money to do cgi
they just got real actors
they said tom put the book back on and
get outside
okay while they doing that i can find
the actual string where
is it the walking bridge constructor the
walkie
there it is that's how i go for y'all
wow
he acted like this was some hot stuff
going on
all castles all right
get some he said get something
for the next three days there are more
bridge constructors
with in-depth looks have you ever wanted
to build a bridge
apocalypse was coming
feedback as you
[Music]
let's go
in a world gone strange
this this is a switch exclusive right
don't put that energy or by switch
yo this is switch madness right here
though
but you see the frames per second that's
not it though not a switch i'll take
that of a switch
this is pinnacle switch right here
pinnacle the return of sam and max oh i
remember those
and now it's time to say hello to my
wonderful co-host for o and l
from ign please say hello to sydney
goodman
thank you jeff what's up everyone i'm
sydney goodman and i am
thrilled to be here gamescom is always
such a fun event and throughout the show
tonight
i want to hear all this love for all
this indie passion love
get it i have an award announced
the winner of best nintendo switch games
let's get it
huge
listen look how switch got the good
marketing right now look at this good
presentation
let's go the only only switch switch
look at this premium premium
presentation all right y'all throwing
switches in the
thing budget take them just check them
in the bushes
awesome thank you back to y'all jim
the gamecom studio and also awesome
indies and i'm gonna be on the daily
show tomorrow so looking forward to that
all right well on to our next game oh
wow
are you going to be okay and players
will journey beyond the more yeah
of azeroth to a place where no living
soul should be okay before
the shadow lands the afterlife of an
entire warcraft universe
the infinite realms of the shadow lands
are watched over by different factions
known as covenants
each holding dominion over a different
aspect of the afterlife
and depending on how someone lived their
mortal life they may end up as part of
one of these covenants when they cross
over
today we're excited to give you a closer
look at the noble and pure
kirian covenant isn't it that game um
this is world of warcraft here we get it
blizzard entertainment
is looking like basic cable y'all savage
we we was laying down in the bushes you
know chilling yo
i would get bread and stuff made for me
didn't know who i was with
very worldly spooky
y'all learned y'all get sucked into this
world y'all maybe you can't heard about
that game this is the original
that's the addiction before that's the
money sucker yeah
oh yeah you'll figure it out thank
[Music]
nick
[Music]
it's all about final fantasy 14 for me
this might be the way to get king back
into the pc though
there ain't nothing to get me back into
the pc i'll tell you this they say if
they say game pass at the end of this
he's in
i mean everyone should get off that wire
and get on that final fantasy 14.
i'm not worried about none of that pc
stuff but my series that's come out and
that joint is obsolete
and y'all dudes is dead okay you know
the new graphics card is twenty thousand
dollars right god bless
the light
1400 30 90.
nothing but still pictures this your
skill picture
that's all i'm here for no i don't know
i don't know why kyle ain't going crazy
for this he's going crazy for that
crappy game that they showed at the
micro joint joints
with
that
control that doesn't
do you have trust you know both of them
got mouse and keyboard support right
black one said people are asking for
game play like it's crack yeah
ain't got nothing coming man
how was you in the afterlife
after like this mad whack my guy
so you mean everything i fought for was
a lie facts
[Music]
and this is long on this you should
touch this playstation
division paid a lot of money for this i
feel like
i feel like i don't even need to play
like i'm getting
all the narrative she separated his soul
from his playstation 4.
you cannot
you you would be wrong that's not all
the narrative that's just one of the
branches
this is just one branch this is just one
branch of the narrative
you believe that you got i already got
destiny i'm good
you cannot go back to that
so bad keg is creating his own narrative
with this game right now
you're standing in front of the
playstation gods
so what do you mean i challenge you
you know i'm backing bad for you what
are you crazy all that money i spent
all those games keep the old console
then
i can't afford it
i'm leaving this realm i'm going to
microsoft
i'm back with news those dudes ain't
doing no back-to-back right
the fight feel dominance maximum
expenses
i don't like when it's matching up with
the cinematography of your words
i don't like when she had the wigs and
he said phil dominance like that
i think i take the x i got wings now
[Music]
come back compact could be yours
all you must do is just pledge
allegiance
[Laughter]
all you had to do was back
look how disrespectful he just dropped
playstation 5 in the hell
said if you do not form genesis with us
you're going to the dark side i've never
been so happy to see an emblem of my
life
shadowlands drop the marketing bag
on this show
all right hope you guys enjoyed that
exclusive look at bastion now we know
many of you can't wait to experience
shadow lands
and our friends at blizzard want you to
know the weight
is almost over still dominance maximum
there really is and we're talking more
about this game
oh we getting the part two
no you're getting stained you're getting
the kick
baby just so you thought it was over
[Music]
i felt like they could show this earlier
and then just end it
yeah i agree
i could have watched an episode
overwatch
with that one you're sinister that
looked like once all right senator you
win
i'm gonna tell you this right now if
there's one game that can kill destiny
for me
yeah i know this [ __ ] game yeah if this
joint comes through raids
yeah if this come to go or this will win
if i see a console over with him
you see king with a new wife come in
heaven new one or a couple
[Applause]
all right but now it's time
for the first time with a project from a
canadian studio
oh yeah canada let's go
world premiere
they corrupted divided
conquered until
finally for the gates of the
celestial realm oh warhammer yes
okay dab talk your talk baby this is you
okay that's legit he's riding a dragon
drive acting like you ain't never seen
his bars off
this is his game
okay okay h of sigma okay look at death
act like he playing any of this
he is nintendo switch switch coming in
hot let's go
look at that
of course had to come back for opening
night live so let's bring them out
everybody crash bandits
what he's wear
[Music]
[Music]
let's get it yo if you pull up on the
microsoft building i'm passing out
if you got the megaphone outside of
microsoft headquarters i'm going to pass
out he won't because he on microsoft
he'd be like yo where's your halo
where's your halo down i will pass out
somebody do it be better be messy saudi
jumping
what
he was giving you 86 bars back when he
had something that was good
they are kind of a peak of this old
aggressive crash to the 90s
crashing coco before the events of crash
bandicoot 1.
and they're kind of these devious puzzle
rooms that we've made
uh his stream right now
super creative and we can't wait to get
people's hands on our vote
yeah no i i got to play demo this a few
weeks ago and that was a challenge so i
can't imagine
i love your statue
[Music]
sure so players actually have there you
go there you go there goes your
playstation 5.
there it is they can pick up and to
actually pick them up they have to reach
you to hdr
without dying it's kind of our homage to
the death roads
from the original trilogy so please
very very smart one of the things that
we got a chance to watch
everybody flub it up and mess up it was
really kind of funny
and then he's going to give you exactly
what everybody's been talking
that we know about the franchise but not
stupid at all very
very intelligent kind of a unique
perspective to the franchise
this is the moment when cortex is really
excited
about the prospect of crash being on
somebody
[Music]
what was it um
this might be the worst event all year
like hold on what's this what's this
i have become a terrorist
predator a rupture
the outright
right
look like it's hard
[Music]
outright isn't whatever it takes
i'm not going to front though the
whatchamacallit looks really nice
the lore of it yeah i like the lord the
aesthetic very um
post-apocalyptic demonic
mixed with a little bit of uh necromancy
well if it is it's probably the story
mode i guess yeah yeah i'll write this
in the building salute that looks really
good i feel like i have to do acid to
play that oh my god
you're always looking to do acid
syndrome the sun is out today look like
i need to do acid
there's never been more reasons
yo did you see those two enemies um
combined i keep seeing this on facebook
like what are the ads on facebook what's
this
it's some game on facebook hey look look
yeah this is stupid this hype escape
they keep trying to force this game on
me
yeah i see it on facebook all the time
hey where's the switch though no no what
download this is an anime style soccer
thing you know what's crazy got a long
name y'all
this is an anime style soccer game this
may they consistently played the switch
in
months listen listen i'll be playing my
switch i'll be playing panasonic but yo
this is an anime soccer game y'all it's
crazy
that's good they need to do something
whatever it is
yeah i haven't played soccer since what
uh fifa 19.
let me know whatever that was like
this is another warhammer game suffering
away like
ants legal death you got difficult
for the rich boys
wait this doesn't look like warhammer at
all this looks different
thank god
i'm a gamer xbox one
right nobody pays
whatever it's all mine you're gonna get
a mario version of this they're gonna
dump it down
right and quite online the next
generation of console will clearly allow
more creative driven games that i hope
you look like he played vr all day
all kinds
i just want to leave this round i just
don't feel like dying
i'm in a whole different place
and just play vr all day
i have a maid that comes and changes me
twice a day
you know one of the things i love about
opening night is that we can show you
the
biggest games in the eastern tribes you
never get tired
it comes from a team of two in sweden
collapse
over the past three years developer
dennis gustafson has built his own vr
unit the playstation
what he's building has absolutely blown
me away so i asked dennis to prepare a
special trailer just for tonight
i hope you're equally inspired by the
two people in sweden so you know these
are the best games
let's see tear it out the ones that hold
it can't
[Music]
stop it
goes the sushi man lego game whatever
how they doing this and they don't move
it's kind of impressive technologically
that they already showed
amazing they already showed this
literally yes
okay it's down to the part now now this
is the part where
two-man teams are the greatest teams
ever you get those big teams
that people can't communicate these two
dudes has got to get together
this is like minecraft with some next
level joint but
it's fully destructible though this is
this is 120 frames a second this is
legit
i'll tell you right now they feel like
that potential it may not be for us
but this no this is for me magazine i
like this
i like the 120 frames per second i like
the world i love
two people did this that didn't look
like 140 frames yeah that's frame pacing
right there
well i i think i didn't have that issue
because i'm watching a different stream
you still
what i am saying he's watching on the
series x that's what he's doing
creativity and destruction look at it
that's very beautiful
it's very good look at the boat game
okay
what's up look at god you don't try to
give a process
but you see the podcast who check out
the particle effects with the um with
the smoke
yeah last year nightmares
well the team at tarsus really really
hasn't shown anything
since but that changed right now
look at the gameplay of little
nightmares 2 which is coming
next february with more to come through
yes it is
including that's when the king gets to
play oh boy
back to nightmare creatures
[Music]
[Applause]
chris loves all the stuff that he got to
pay for
this is the best thing they've shown
this year they look good though i'm
getting um
what you call it vibes um
oh i see it at the bottom it says um all
of this is captured on a series x
oh because it looked good
this is giving me inside my god it's
looking good y'all i can't
i gotta take it back it looks spooky as
hell
yo
that little pictures the first one was
good yeah
did you play no i don't know
he had fraud for life he got his fraud
membership
oh no i'm out i'm out are they messing
with people right now they're messing
with people right
you now because you didn't play the
first one yo don't remember adding the
one with the butcher we need a room with
the butcher
yeah yeah that just crazy yo
you look crazy is it co-op
[Applause]
yeah this look good y'all this is a good
streaming game yeah i'm thinking to play
this
it looked funny he just knocked the
stuffing out
literally this is like fire i care for
it y'all shout out to game over brown
three dollar track super chat king game
pop
my on my brand new tcl
studio is that wwe hall of famer jerry
the king yeah
is
are you down with me
you know me
oh
this game look [ __ ] but i'm telling
you this guy's just going to go crazy on
the game pre-order switch
y'all know what it is that's right
playstation 5 day one launch game
let's
see these games look good it's just if
are they easy to control
how many supers you get permanent
it's rigged
no it's just awards for like best of
show basically
okay you mean the the game that wasn't
at the show
is star wars squadrons
is operation tango
operation yeah you see you could tell
this isn't a proper reward
black ruining see that's the switch
marketing right here that that's why
this type of presentation we get
i used to be an explorer the winner of
best indie game is curious expedition
two
[Music]
it was time for the world i just wish
they'd show me destiny so i can get
ready for work congratulations they
should have just had e3
and just said you know just had you
signed a waiver if you wanna catch it
catch it let's get it
oh i get it
right here because we've turned
craigslist
gamescom now
ever late night talk show our gamescom
awesome indie show the freshest deep
cuts in indie gaming
and finally the gamescom best of show
including this thing better not be
overdue
scream you alive you're still breathing
you know they're just holding it off
one more thing and the galactic empire
intense 5v5
today we'll get a glimpse of what
squadron's story has to offer by taking
it
i've literally said multiple times one
of the first games i played
[Music]
or destruction
but the heroic pilots of the rebel
alliance have chosen to keep
fighting to show the empire that we are
not
afraid it was their bravery that ended
palpatine's reign
and brought about our new republic
however
the empire lives on shattered though it
may be
as i speak imperial forces are edging
but the galaxy is changing and you can
be a part of it
with the help of brave and daring pilots
this war can
end make a choice
change our galaxy for the better
hi i'm suzanne hunker narrative producer
on star wars squadrons
our single players everybody tuning in
they thought they would see some hot
playstation 5 or
some serious extra you know maybe they
might drop the prize
i hear you're the reason i was able to
finally get a concert
we're giving you a glimpse of an early
imperial mission behind enemy lines
one of our spies agent thorne has
discovered vital intelligence on
projects
your mission is
they walked away from there
the genius of nintendo they take
something that's really hot they dumb it
down and put goofy little dudes on it
and then people be like that's legit
customize and master this dollar tree
i think it's october
to setting a trap
right here dude
[Music]
we already know what platforms is not
available on that is not all ea has to
share from the galaxy far
far away today all this is
representative of everything
but you can visit
the millennium
this incredible adventure at disneyland
resort walt disney world resort that
inspired
the scene what are they selling too
[Music]
[Music]
let's go ea drop that sims bag i get
y'all sell
billions y'all know what time it is they
ain't not doing that over there
let's go switch
yeah they make babies and stuff over
there i'm not getting that over there
this definitely looks like a switch this
is a switch come on put these switches
up that's right come on down my fingers
we need this for the crew for the game
this one did you see the world billions
you saw it they got more than three
people on the screen
this cutscene would completely crash the
gang y'all
forte put the switches up got raised
with the switch you gotta know what this
would do
it's over for y'all in here mohawk and
switzerland
oh man look at those pixels you see how
many people on the screen
bro we could totally handle this
[Music]
i
[Music]
you know
this is 12 minutes i actually really
like this game they showed it at e3
oh shut up y'all because
[Music]
[Music]
killing it oh and remember the switch
don't come with sound oh lord
it's either oh defoe's voice that was
the phone that was a waste of my time
it's like it's like it's like the
playstation you gotta juggle the
graphics
redemption i did not like that there's
no redemption for this
this man is literally setting himself up
to follow everyone
he likes to do it self-deprecating
another thing he's gonna be so extra
in this trailer elbow this looks good
here but we know that's not in the game
he said that elbow was crazy
he said did you see the elbow
i'd rather play that extinction game
before i play this
oh i'm gonna tell you right now the
armor look better the armor look better
that's not saying much oh no i know we
ain't cutting that off i know that's not
what we're doing out here
[Music]
i appreciate that laughs guys
hey
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's on the x though switch got
this 128 french got this
i ain't got it like this which has
warframe sir they ain't say 290.
this is not the 290 edition the gateway
i will say this looks good i i'm not
going to catch
and on pokemon they joint was just like
throw the game into the world and then
it will
fix it around and do things through it
what they say one friend got more speed
yeah
you felt fuzzy stop it
switch game told you let's go
there's nothing switch yo they said it
not this version
they
yeah switch basic version 290p
we work very hard to make sure that we
bring you next level graphics and
for us not to be able to scale all the
way up when we're in the chat to time on
god foreign
it's like they did that to me
[Music]
y'all
ninjas
ninjas sprinkles
[Music]
lollipop buses
this is because switch can't have more
combat they got this
robot
it will not look like this i don't know
i don't know i don't wanna get gas
when are they gonna start showing
gameplay
yeah i played the first one
nevermind there's too many particle
effects
or likes yeah they just put
right one inside on game yeah what's on
the gang y'all it's on the game you was
right emperor it's on the game
there we go all right guys we're back
officially looking like virtual hours
we've got an hour more of great stuff to
show you destiny
stasis you're going to see a bracelet
fall
guys season 2 and clank
but right now on september 25th he said
an hour or more
you know you're not you know you know
sovereign is watching that work
dialogue not laughing right now i ain't
losing no money over this feeling
1920s this is this is cognito there's
cars
oh it's gangster let's begin let's go
those gritty little mafia textures let's
get it
we got a whack guys we're gonna we gonna
whack busting your back doing an honest
day's work
that's been trying to scrape you off
what you know about this era son this is
prohibition let's get it
get it all type of cd dealer oh you know
it's lit when they got that tommy gun
when they got that tommy gun
it's lit
let's go i'm in let's go what you know
about that
i want my money on tuesday
[Music]
there dude i said it's not i said no
switch
of course not no i was talking to you a
turn-based movie yeah carson
fps from a team in montreal canada
lemnis gate
is coming in early 2021 and has a unique
mechanic that's around a
25 absolutely rules check this out
you need to get me for the hype right
the fight is i'll get you jay lit
he said the tin based rts be right
through it they were like oh this guy
black hold on definitely in turn base
yeah what is
i'm i'm paying attention yeah yeah what
is this
it looks like hot garbage
i don't understand
they trying anything when they're in
cove bubbles
with bubbles oh you're right your turn
your king is right
this is and clay
this is the multiplayer get ready to
experience memorable moments
star wars films
oh you know it's about to get nasty
right now you're about to lose 25
minutes of your life
scream save me with some commentary
screams oh god
let go like my father
you know he's sitting there disbelief
right you help me
save me
[Music]
mass effect
this itself it's oh wow
they're putting money in things with
ourselves you know you're my only hope
he said you do not have the high ground
anakin
do not trust me
for real like how many like is it like
20 is it like a
you know like a criteria you need like
at least this many star wars games
every year
not like this i'm telling you you can't
do it like this
this is awesome
why
[Music]
every lego star wars there is
[Music]
i'm a sucker for all of this though
that's the funny thing i do like
something crazy i'll be in the
background y'all looking at my
achievements
your full game is going this way y'all
yeah this is a game pass or a hard pass
this is the truth
everything a hard pass for me god bless
like my father before me
it'll look nice suggesting
[Music]
[Laughter]
behind it he said i am your father
lightning down there he's ridiculous
man lego star wars looks so fun coming
to next gen as well
all right we'll be right back with more
world premieres from huge new games like
ratchet and clay
will depart medal of honor above and
beyond
destiny 2. but before the only people
are playing
tonight on nintendo switch and steam
it's called
exclusive
let's go when you're the market leader
you get them
this is pc this is pc he's like
switching
[Music]
struggling that's what they're going to
be in the next gen struggling
throwback productions you know what king
when you get stressed this looks like
super when you
ask when you get into the movie said you
insane
yo y'all foul when you get a nintendo
switch yo run that
king when you get a nintendo switch this
is the stuff that you got to play
right this is coming to steam see steam
is the lead platform and
i heard switch the beginning
cross-generational
thing let's go
i am so good with this right here
like what's this
oh this is all you already know it's def
turn up
turn up yes turn up death
this actually is going to be a good game
i think this
is this is going to be good too they
they really redid it huh this is like an
85 above game
yeah you're gonna get this smoke this
looking switch ready
[Music]
oh i got one on this one let's go though
here we go
we got enough for this ah
unfortunately you're gonna have to buy
it no it's not it's on gamepad
no this is the second one this is the
new one oh okay
[Music]
wait what medal of honor this impeller
first baby
slobo said the x would run that at 15
frames per second
what's this you said chris that day no
that was uh is that like a lovecraft
playoff that
that's literally how diller described it
a couple nights ago
he said i'm so bored up on project trash
no no no this game is horrible
it tries to beat every racer
it's very funny guys here we go
i have a few games that i binge play
relax yourselves all the crazy stuff
that you're playing
go crazy really a big one for me where
that's
you know trash rooms when they do green
screens
you'll be happy to know that ign is
going to help you guitar games a guitar
game is lit she's not playing
where you can get all the daily
highlights and a late night show
experience
from gamers for gamers back to you jeff
back to you jackie
tell me why this game is being talked
about as we know there's tell me why
you're trying to force this game
the best for
we've all felt that in
amongst 2020 the games and trailers all
right well one game tell me why sony's
being so scared of microsoft
dropping prizes has launched a
reforestation project by planting a game
is a dark space combat shooter where
players take control of nara
everyone in the chat give me some tell
me why phrases man someone said tell me
i'm officially muting this until they
show me something nice
all right well i'm looking forward to
this so what's this get break it down
for us now
so it's a table i want an actual good
sydney shootout
tell me why people still buy tcs
christopher you're regulated until i
said tell me why jeff is not in the
bushes yeah
yeah she regulated your message someone
said tell me why halo if it is the late
of 2022.
tell me why this show should have been
on youtube tell me why it sounds like a
janitor
wow see this is this is that joint right
this looks like a little star foxy no
this is the joint for the um the series
x this is my day one
this is all launched yeah this is that
game this game is
yeah i was looking for a good space
fighter tell me why they're trying so
hard
tell me why ssd is greater than power
okay
stay in here see that stadium logo no
i'm not gonna look i told you he's
camping for everything no i didn't know
they was alive
well soon the fall guys experience will
evolve with season two
there's a lot of new stuff that's what i
want and tonight i just want people
i just want to get a hot fad real quick
and catch the bag
what's next get ready we lit
yo i know
that's right number one game in the
world i don't care
in the quest for ultimate
the colors just look like nah don't wash
well with me
[Music]
that's exactly what it is it looks like
you're getting burned you said this game
can come with a happy meal
on this show by next week
you said tell me why middle age dude
playing this game
yeah for real got too much testosterone
for this oh
this is a great game this is a great
game
got the early accessory
[Music]
it's a great game shout out to sonaldo
we got a chance to touch that at pax
[Music]
wasteland three uh iron man oh you
talking about waves one yeah turn base
really good uh great narrative i
couldn't get into it i couldn't get into
wasteland too i couldn't get it i
couldn't get into it this is completely
i was asking myself what was phil
thinking that's his first thing i said
in my head i was like oh filter messed
up
this game is amazing this game is so
much better than wasteland 2 it's not
even funny
okay okay i'll take your word for it
did you know who i'm coming for when i
play then they ain't right right
it's cold guys that's all that matters
oh god daddy put the game passes in the
chat you already got a vibe
fuzzy
was that was a 360 no it's original xbox
the original xbox
graphics insane sounds
like ogx masters at this time because my
appreciation
i noticed it was um the reason why i
liked it so much it was
real solid like the graphic the
oh this dude we got to get
i already know what you're talking about
make sure you put the picture up on
twitter brother they don't let you run
around with guitars
i appreciate it good games you deserve
that we've always been a day one
when i
becoming clearly more important for a
lot of people
you know play is a natural instinct and
from
they're about to show a lot hold on
we're talking to the goat hold on
next week above and beyond we knew we're
gonna hold on right here
powerful exciting single player you said
we got just a control bot next week
who directed the original medal of honor
in 1999 is back at the helm of this
project
you'll hear more from him in just a bit
peter and i actually worked together on
medal of honor allied association
craft a completely new experience in vr
the team is creating a riveting and
emotional journey through world war ii
like you would have never
changed that man the personal stories
yeah the veterans and survivors of the
war
they got them starving
you're producing no gage
and the game's captured
so they're making the next medal of
honor yeah yeah
they need that though the following game
it's vr only
yeah i need a real vr then some of you
will see because that playstation ain't
cutting it
on all of you king tell me why you
bought a playstation
i was on the hype train brother i'm
cleaning on mine
i'm tethered to the streets
welcome to france gentlemen i'm looking
good though
oculus facebook
his head up with that statue
i don't know how you move around the
world somebody could tell they living
room up
you better put another tc yellow alone
i'm just saying this
[Music]
tell me why people always be giving
excuses to vr well
the reason why is vr is doing double a
display
like i said because you know each eye
has to be 60 frames per second
each eye has to you know high resolution
this does look like one of the better
looking videos
shout out to vince for taking it away
from putting it in the same
vein as call of duty yeah battlefield
and making it stand out if not for the
lord
i feel you did you see the background
that look it looks
really good man
yo that's my man over there
bring him back now somebody get visceral
state yeah
is it me or are they about to end this
pedestrian incredible and now
looks like they're going to end it with
the best i knew they were going to
escape
where y'all could just throw your pcs in
the bushes experience your half-life
alex look better definitely i gotta say
the trailer
really grabbed me such an idea over
there giving a premium talk
so i can't do that thank you for having
us on the show the i'm
representing a whole team back at reef
climbing man right here
really hard on this and it's uh it's so
exciting to premiere the trailer
uh with you great magnificent
i use a lot of essential oils on it i've
never
been able to work on it i like to pull
it on the sides
you know that's my trouble spots but
right now
i found out i got an activated juice
that i throw under my neck
perspective but there are
five billion counts fantastic and the
story follows
you got that 5k thread count though if
it ain't salt baby i don't want it baby
who's sleeping on that brillo
[Music]
make sure you mix it with the lavender
juice
around your perspective gotta have the
smells with it the smell you gotta be
legit
as if you are there so it creates a much
more intimate and
uh and i say this in all real characters
i love the things that's going on around
you
i got you know i have the xbox news
ready they shouted us out they said we
cannot stop laughing during the
lord's livestream keep it up
[Music]
tell me why that man brought up
switchboards man we tried to get away
from that we ain't trying to bring that
up we don't want that negativity in our
lives
as well um you know paying tribute um to
everyone that uh
as soon as this is done don't forget to
tell us why you got to do it which is
something that respawn is really
what i got different single player
experience but i hear you what would i
also be doing
oh i thought he said he gotta go kick
his mother
[Music]
like making duck feel good and one of
the hardest ones is is leaning
and in vr you know how you duck you just
duck and and how you lean in vr you
you just lean and so the ability to lean
around
it's been a long time on this vr time
yeah
level
[Music]
but i think the man right here
definitely i mean
his mustache
okay
uh
let's see
[Music]
oh
[Music]
right there see the lighting it'll break
slow mo set celebrate yeah yeah i do
look like it
oh that beat sounds crazy that's like a
saturday morning oh
[Music]
that's the xbox series x open floor
racer
killing everybody right here see look
look look that
you know what that is that's insomniac
right there
[Music]
crazy even king is in you know what time
it is if king is in
that's good
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah what do you think they're
playing this song king
damn
you know what i don't like about mobas
if it don't hit like day one
they really you know supported yeah
yeah because remember gigantic for on
the xbox
launches yes it's actually launching i'm
in the discord for
okay okay yeah i'm in the discord for
spell breaking nintendo switch
i told you so shady we do that i told
you
they're gonna start getting associated
for everything oh let's go let's get
that 10.
that perfect 10 cinderella
minecraft dungeons so you're getting
this and i'm getting commercial
i get ripped
sir
oh i gotta go all right bro yeah you're
gonna miss custody too damn
i can't help they spent an hour wasting
my time
i'll let you know how it is
i'm not gonna front whoever is doing
their trailers for game pass
they're working yeah they got it they're
gonna have to mock it
i'm gonna tell you right now i think
neon the best is probably the most
played game in game pass right now
you see i got that perfect ted in the
middle with that flexibility
it is shut up so he ain't missing
nothing slow said you can leave you
ain't missing
a death dude no i'm definitely gonna
play um
the resident evil over there i'm gonna
sound my resonator with my playstation
4.
let's go yeah tell me why microsoft
can't advertise everything else this way
the way they do game pads
tell me why you're right you're right
yeah you know you got an x cloud
right now they commercials for their
services link
i am not going
[Music]
let me know when playstation starts
doing some advertising or anything
[Music]
dirty man
that's right i'm a cat for mine
[Music]
yes
one of the most legendary german games
of all time created by
factor five the logo just makes me feel
warm inside
you're ridiculous
as far as possible i'd say they're one
of the greatest
indie developers of all time
yes
i've been there ever since to this day
it's wonderful
sega yeah with genesis
[Music]
[Music]
i don't even know how what we'll do
don't bring it back what they doing
in june oh let's go leave destiny 2 that
starts on november
who did this for you
how you feeling right now
europa
[Music]
oh
because the police station would be
salty come on what's the titan go what's
the title
that's you let's see where the hunter is
dog salt
[Music]
oh
crucible going crazy no how much it
costs on the playstation it breaks so
much
with that like platforming ability
look at that that's crazy and jump over
it
like it was nothing yeah right you saw
that right
embrace the darkness this is when they
come back to the zone
i might play the game free daddy down
baby game fast you win
that's hbo right there that's showtime
that might be the day that the xbox come
out of course there are even more awards
than the ones that i announced tonight
so check out the gamescom awards
username playstation
playful price so you get it all gave up
which again
dlc come out monday august 30th at 8pm
all right well a lot of people have been
wondering let me fanboy for you next
generation
different fatalities generation
well back in
from insomniac june a title which uses
them let's get it
saying clips i'm definitely leaving
because i don't want to hear them
experience that insomniac says is only
possible on brand new hardware
now it's time for you to decide if you
see the difference here's an extended
uninterrupted demo of live playstation 5
gameplay
of ratchet and clank rift apart let's
get it enjoy
we have only available on playstation
until pcs get better assistant
five the most powerful ssd in the
business inside yeah let's get it
clutch man through the altitude chat
watch it late love the intro code
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
disappear on the floor but let's keep it
going let's go let's go
i gotta go play part one right now and
go
this
this looks like casual difficulty oh
i just want to see the difference
between the playstation 4 and
playstation fire don't see it yet
it's regulated there it is
it is we okay we already know that
they're going for cinematic mode
all right let's stop acting like this
this is probably 1440p
up red yes silvo sega hey
okay okay let's get you hey some frames
up
they do they do if you play the other
one it does
they don't know how to furry look how
they enter in the world like that
that's crazy that's that's as deep
that's that's
i got to go back and look at the other
one he looked crazy i'm telling you
yeah yeah i know you didn't play the
first one right there i played a really
really good oh
son you see he just pulled the world in
yeah that's the ssd
that right there it's crazy yes do it
they have a gun like that on the other
one
it's a little bit different
you think miles is pushed back
no no no no i'm talking about first
i belong i think you have to sell the
system if anything is going to get
pushed back into this but
why not showing any miles that is true i
don't know why not
they're showing this but i think this is
what i'm saying
they're showing this they're showing now
because i think this is more reflective
of what you can show with new technology
as opposed to models which we know let's
be really
traveling in the city yeah but yo well
that's really going to show his frame
rate you're not going to get these types
of moments this is what's going to
showcase
what this ssd what they've been told
hey at least with something else
i just feel like this is probably a
better showcase for more technique
before he does anything
i totally agree with that part right i'm
just saying there's a lack of
showing no i agree with you though i am
upset that we still haven't seen
real game players oh look at the floor
you see the floor see-through yeah
you're like oh god
are you implying that this is a
playstation 5 unlike
i'm just implying that this is yeah
definitely a representative of
playstation 5 tech
more than spider-man which is built on
in the
you know original game there's a story
version
i'm not going to get into it well i mean
this is basically built off the old tech
too but
um with the ray tracing and
implemented this this is not one hell of
a leap over the last one
it's just the mechanics that's built
around it is definitely
really makes me want to go play the
first one again
they got to refine it with this frame
rate up
definitely if that ssd is all that fast
um still seeing a lot of frame issues
but it's early in development
not to be expected at launch we have to
get the dimension away from nefarious
oh yeah you know the playstation dude is
watching this and they wanted it to be
flawless but it's not
so they said they're like
there's a little slight fragment yeah
it's still quite famous come on man
the truth is
get a hold of you he got you in a half
an hour and a half an hour
everybody go to digital foundry because
the news is going to be out
breaking news richard better tells the
truth
oh that's all they wanted they wanted
y'all to chill your hand now richie
gonna buzz it over
[Laughter]
that's like that [ __ ]
they say that chad said this is the
exact same devil yes it is
[Music]
i'm not just showing you the same thing
before
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
that you've never seen before
um
[Music]
a couple of months ago
with the controller with the adapter and
closed it up next party
what's your mail with the one outfit
anywhere to say
for the weapons
laughing
so there's a nice intuitive way of
basically raising the skill ceiling
and giving you more ways to play better
wow no i'm
excited to see how you guys are going to
roll that out across what i'm sure
is
[Music]
really started in the exact same spot
in the exact same spot is that something
you're going to see like it's like
you're just playing that they didn't get
that
outside i guess i'm curious about how
often you use that technique richard
better go 10 y'all a new one and a half
and i said they show some more
get your videos
let's get into it
he said did you see the particle effect
did you see the 15 frames per second
they meant to do that they were trying
to do the matrix style of ratchet and
clings
right to the launch window
all right that's all we're gonna get i'm
sure ratchet and clank ripped apart
coming in the launch window for
playstation five i gotta say uh
insomniac
uh we're so excited about what you guys
are doing here across playstation
and uh the game looks incredible so
thank you the launch window
all you've done i didn't know if it was
going to drop the show
what does launch window mean to you from
november to december
not if they say it get delayed if they
don't say they won't get delayed
until we see boy my house is not gonna
be there you sure
yeah because we ain't see it cause it's
not there
oh man well that was it wow funny study
show what's the problem that did show a
lot of the same thing with that one
man [ __ ] up baby let's finish this up
man
[Music]
what a show what a show
thank you brother have a good thanks
[Music]
man he was quiet sit in the bushes
so yeah just definitely the bushes i'm
just playing something
no my wife is on the phone so oh okay
okay i just wanted to know like yeah
your thoughts
real quick
the show in general yeah just overall
it wasn't really it was not a good it
wasn't a good show
too short of destiny too much action and
playing
not worth it oh my god so there's was
there anything
besides the uh dusty anything else you
liked
um the one that looked like inside yeah
a little nightmares right yeah that the
nightmares too i'm definitely down with
that's what's up that's what's up no
doubt wilhelm
scream yes sir what's going on man
overall
thoughts gamescom 2020 reaction
how you feeling any standouts for you
not a lot for me i mean as far as just
things that i'll probably will play
squadron is definitely in my like
i'm thinking about it you know like i
like flight sims so
something where i could play with like
buddies that would be kind of fun yeah
quite something like that
uh i really feel like we did wait a long
time to see
a little bit of destiny yeah they really
milked us yeah man
a little bit more of that you know i
don't actually know
if they're did they really show too much
different anything different than
the uh previous reveal no not much not
much
it was chopped and screwed the same way
you know but not that's your part let me
know
okay one thing i the one thing i
actually missed though was uh
they i think they showed like just a
little picture of like the exotic that's
gonna come with the expansion i'm not
sure exactly which one that was they
showed something in the right corner i
gotta go back and watch it again
um but other than that yeah i mean it
was certainly fun being here
i defer all my other time to king
thank you thank you sir appreciate
where we at man this whole show gone
first of all
um shout out to jeff kegley and the team
um for bringing the presentation
that has uh been
really done well uh i forgot who did the
the
next presentation that i thought was
done really well too oh oh dc fandom
yeah um and it's up in there we so we're
seeing people get hitting their strides
with these shows
going forward and uh and and jeff
even uh attempting this to the level
that he's attempting it is fantastic
the the people that he had on i love
medal of honor that i saw
yeah yeah the world the world craft um
a lot of games that i did see a lot of
little games i got to watch it again
because i was having fun
with you guys so you know joking on the
screen but
um it was a ton of games that was there
that would show that game com that i'm
very interested in
be it in game pass or not in game pass
something i could probably sit around
and wait for
or to see what's you know it's gonna
happen but i like the direction that
we're going in
now um a lot of times uh we come to
these shows
expecting to see uh uh what's going to
happen for the future this is
we're in a very different time right we
don't know price usually around this
time we know price
date structure and everything we have
absolutely no structure everything is
free fall
yeah so we wanted to see some of the
stuff that was going to be launching
this year
on the next generation platforms uh we
got a very small snippet
of godfall yeah which was new footage
yes right which they did be dirty it cut
me so fast
but i would rather have new footage
right
and cut off uh the raw
uncut footage of that we saw of ratchet
and clank and of destiny
right now i think the i what they gave
jeff
was the bee films of both okay
uncut okay you know and so he get the
longer forms of them
so when it was in their trailer forms
before at both shows
we got smaller uh footage of it cut up
so we didn't see the imperfections of
both
uh i don't really see too much
imperfections with the destiny i believe
that's more refined
and you know but ratchet and clank is
you know new tech they're learning it
so um but as much to be uh excited for
right going forward uh but i've noticed
now
what's up we're on a month-to-month type
of thing yeah
yeah it's like trickle effect right
almost triggered
it's like games week we can only get
excited for september
yeah or the furthest out we can get
excited for is october
right right and that's kind of
disheartening for gamers
but at the same time we do have a ton of
games to play so you know continue
playing your games now and then
keep seeing little gems here and there
but if i'm gonna give the show a rating
i'm gonna give it a rating of seven or
eight
yeah um because i saw a lot of titles
that i'm very interested
in and maybe it wasn't those bangers
that we want
and and all that jaw-dropping moment and
stuff like that but
i do think uh next year we're going to
get
more uh titles that we can really sink
our teeth in
right now everybody wants answers and
i think we're walking away we came to
gamescom looking for answers yeah yeah
yeah we didn't get those we didn't get
those facts shout out to drunken ninja
to two hour super chat can we talk about
cyberpunk being the best
playstation game wow you really like
everything from playstation
yeah i mean it was it was an uneven
event um
i think for me where they lost me
initially before the announcements when
they were kind of saying
hey i think someone challenged them as
far as these games are we going to see
new footage and he kind of quelled that
and said look some of this stuff we're
going to see some
say trailers and some stuff and i think
that's what made it disappointing it's
like you said it's like
it's almost like they some they acted as
if some people didn't watch
like the playstation reveal or the xbox
reveal so that was a little
disappointing the indies definitely got
a chance to shine with a lot of stuff
shout out to world of warcraft getting a
lot of a lot of bag
you know what i said they was out there
we don't know if
if they might make it to these consoles
because i do tell you
if y'all guys don't know your
playstation and your xbox both support
mouse and keyboard
now we all know going forward that these
bigger systems
will definitely support it in full
capacity
so a lot of these pc games might make it
over
i don't know yeah we got to see i mean i
think the big games obviously you know
the four guys announcement destiny
stuff i felt the big games didn't get a
lot of shine like and they definitely
try to push towards the end
you know what i'm saying obviously you
know the ratchet incline to me looked
impressive
but at the same time a lot of the same
footage a lot of the
things we've kind of already known about
and um the big news though
release window i i was i'll be honest i
was concerned that that game would not
hit
2020 february yeah and
we got me a kick have a little internal
bet with that actually
like he doesn't know what launch window
means like he's he's gonna act like he's
a newbie
and this this has never happened to him
we don't know what is two
two months two to three months you know
they're like i don't see those three
lines
right okay you said two months two well
it comes okay let's say two months so
november is the launch
no no okay so we don't count the month
of november uh-huh
january december january yeah okay so we
did it
okay so now we we kind of in the same
pocket then next year
next year yo spell break looked amazing
to me
shout out to them i really enjoyed that
there was a couple of indies that got
they shined that i was really feeling
but it didn't look good actually yeah
they look good you know me with the
mafia
shout out to the switch as i was rapping
little things that they were getting you
know what i'm saying
i'm playing i'm not getting hyped for no
game i got in my room right now
shout out to ea for being messy and not
bringing titles to the switch and
breaking hard
but uh that was it i mean overall you
know i'm making sure we're gonna stay
too long with this
kind of uneven you know a little
disappointed i want more it's just a
frustrating
generation for those of us king we come
from that e3 claws
we come from the news everything
consolidated everything in one spot and
it's just like
this bits and pieces and you know here
and i will say this though we've got
call of duty though
call of duty can't front them frames
that look like 120 to me
i don't know what you get call of duty
looks polished
um there's a lot of titles that look
polished but those are titles that we do
know about
and we can we can test a pedigree
because we already know
that th that they will deliver a high
quality uh
uh game right so we know call of duty if
you like it or not
right it's still a high quality big
budget game so
that's not what i was looking for
was new stuff and stuff for next gen
yeah and if you were doing it and like
like i was going in for that you weren't
going to get anything that you really
wanted it from it
so i had to take what was given and what
was given was a decent palette of games
that
you can get a chance to uh try like uh
little nightmares that
that game looks fantastic um look good
yeah this is it's a couple of gems in
there i got to watch it again like i
said
yeah but i'm walking away from it saying
okay
there's uh titles across the rest of
this year well at least for the next
couple of months
that can keep you satiated until you can
get a clearer view
of we don't even got pre-orders around
this time i already have at least
50 pre-orders already pre-ordered i have
zero
we're about to be in september we don't
even have dates
we don't have pre-orders this is
crazy i gotta get my topic together i
thought i was gonna watch this and get a
topic
um you know what i know my topic now
mm-hmm give us the preview for iop
yeah my my topic this sunday is going to
be um
regurgitated game footage um
is it good or is it bad um and and
it's not just ratchet and clank because
destiny did it too yeah that's the i
mean
scream would you say that how much there
was some new but
it was so short and like which was a
little bit more elaborate i would say it
was probably like
i don't know maybe maybe five seconds
added on to each one of the subclasses
they showed the one um
they showed i think the one stasis
effect that that mantling effect
yeah in like a pvp and the pvp that was
the difference yeah they were showing
the powers in pvp settings correct
yeah uh i again i really want to look
i'll probably have to
watch it re-watch five more times to get
through every little
nuance they but it didn't seem
that much more um right
and they definitely milked us to stay to
the end for those they totally did
yeah shout out to regulated super chats
the card for playstation 5 125 frames
per second with low res
and 60 frames per second with 4k how you
doing is low reset
bro he's probably though no i look good
that's probably one of the best visual
showcases of the joint
and then um what was it was the other it
was another game that uh looked at i
mean i mean i thought the um
respawn joint showed well wait a second
wait a second wait a second what's up
call of duty for playstation 500 nothing
they're doing is 120 frames per second
no they stay
they announced it no they don't know
you're going to blow up doing this
come on division announce the spots
when digital foundry get a hold of them
you see what happened and what they had
to do to get to that
you'll figure it out but i'm gonna tell
you right now don't put your feet in
that fire
that's not true my last point my last
point is
shout out to bioware they set it up for
a beautiful redemption
and then i'm like are we getting the
trilogy oh we get it and then they give
him this conceptual lot of dragons on
age and i'm just like
not like this not like this
for you yeah man by the way i thought
this was gonna be the perfect redemption
story for them man they've been through
hell i mean at least we saw some stuff
we got a little bit of gameplay i mean
not not much i don't even call it
gameplay
just yeah i i wanted so much more for
bioware man i thought that was a moment
missed but that's what i got man that's
what i got
you know what i'm saying anybody else
say anything before we roll up out of
here
you know what we do
whatever no statue that i'm in oh look
at you
bro anyway we rather roll it up man sin
let's go talk to the people
tell them where they can find you sin
you never really stream but that's the
first time so we're glad to have
you and all that you know yes sir city's
in the bushes i don't know what he doing
well he could find sinister in the iop
destiny clan
he's always helping and carrying us you
know to our exotics and our raids and
our dungeons and all that that's been
doing that because he's been playing in
on pc but soon yes yes
but let's get uh one of our legendary
content creators the amazing
will helm scream where can i find people
find you sir
you'll find me in sins backpack
uh you can find me on uh youtube wilhelm
scream
twitter wilhelm scream shout out to iron
lords podcast
to uh mario in the background
iron man to the right uh the greatest
man cave i could ever imagine or hope
to have and thank you guys shout out to
anger man no places to five no
price no point one yeah no no prices man
this is
this is crazy yo shot oh what before we
i gotta
say shout out to keg for being in his
bag with the jokes today
because he made this stream bad if you
take it
what was this what was the moment i
could stop it was one part i just killed
it was a couple there was something else
other than that and i was just like yo
yes yes i like my man's beard
yes the big game was lit so salute the
cake with the jokes man where can the
five people find you what's going on sir
you can find me at a king david otw on
twitter
uh having a good time over there uh
you're gonna also find me on
all social media uh iron lords podcast
arthur castle x on friday open mic
statue show
i didn't do the um statute this week and
i have the maji cases there so this
like i told y'all before this whole
thing is going to change all these
little guys they're going to go
into the black into the display cabinets
to have a glass display cabinets back
there
but um i have the magic cases that's
going to take up this whole side of this
wall iron man's night was supposed to be
here so when he mentioned iron man i was
like
iron man what behind him supposed to be
here his life side bus i got that
there's something new in the box behind
you by the way what's in the box
what's in the box yeah all those statues
and stuff like that and
in in this box right here we're supposed
to be this
week um but we're doing the show
so you know as team players what we have
to do
we have to let content breathe right so
during the week from
monday to wednesday you definitely get
all the log uh lognet stuff
and i definitely want you on the website
at lognet
and then on thursday you will get a king
of the statues but today we're doing the
show we're doing the show tomorrow
you get uh the last word we're loyal
cognito
yes and then you know on saturday we're
taking a breath
we're getting our galvanizing our
batteries getting ready for sunday
give you the best podcast show that we
can possibly give you guys
you already know shout out to funny
building brother did he say yo 290 p.a
you know me yes
that was that was that was it that was
the one for him man he made the show the
stream lit man salute man
so you already know what it is man yo
it's y'all for pulling up this is a fun
little j
i made it entertaining you know i'm
saying yo again salute to all the
podcasts unlock
love man it was it was it was
overwhelming just to see the community
oh yeah
listen let's let's let's all bend the
knee the lower cognito to going on
unlock having the time of his life
living in his element and dropping
jaw-dropping facts
that basically kind of had the world
like what
and i know a certain somebody was
watching the show
somebody's advice i mean all that made
things happen
we're gonna talk about it we're gonna
talk about a sunday man definitely halo
infinite
topic was was was definitely a highlight
for for us
but yes a lot to those guys man
everybody like i said for pulling up
the love was tremendous you made a
brother i'm saying i was like damn like
i never felt that before you know it's
there for the whole
community you know so that was love and
um yeah uh what i was going to say
cognito unlock your salute actually
special announcement is a strong chance
tonight if you're the destiny fans
please tune in and show a chance your
boy might get the call
for um what you call five team chat on
ign so we'll see what happens i don't
want to jinx it yeah
but um yeah we'll see what's going on
we'll try to talk about the stasis all
that good stuff
again support the realm support lords of
gaming.net we're doing a lot of big
things out here support wilhelm's screen
because he never tweets his videos and
he's one of the best content creators in
the destiny community
outside of my manny bontes as well you
know what i'm saying so salute to him
again if you're
but yo scream wilhelm scream man again
tremendous just add me to his uh tweet
it out
can i definitely make sure that y'all
get it
but no doubt man appreciate y'all around
and then sound like i said sunday we
will be back i mean last will be friday
um sunday you already know we back in
the room 1pm
get it in get it out so that's it
regulated everybody put your crest up
we're going to leave you with can't get
slap slow though yeah he said five t
chat you guys could nod off disgusting
oh my god you betsy you messy slow-mo is
the messy man
i love them but look everybody look at
your day again check out for us we gonna
leave y'all with that nice little king
intro for y'all to join the realm for
those who have not and we catch up with
y'all man so we are here
series x guys you already know please
hi i'm lord king david of iron lords
podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's two
ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
hit that joy button you hit that join
button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in our
community
and this community is beautiful
so remember you can have one entry
by hitting that join button and becoming
a member of the realm
and also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
that's the who did that for you
sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man